hätten sie mal das video gucken also
bräuchte das video verbreitet sind nicht
das loch da werdet ihr nicht schwanger
werden richtig ehrlich was wir da jetzt
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich habe
heute wieder papa was wenn ein prinz
haga clement und den russen hätten
natürlich in der video beschreibung auf
jeden fall ja jetzt jetzt bist du dran
jetzt übergeben
ich halte meine lieben heute werden wir
über das thema sagt drehen konnte barry
kemp ordens thema war ein spieler
unserer zuschauer ja noch sehr jung sind
und wir die halt abwarten machen wollen
jawohl veredelt
ja was ist denn die jungen zuschauer
weist also ich denke dass die jungen
zuschauer interessiert eigentlich
analverkehr
#bv10 #bpw ich klicke vollauf münze auf
instagram 12 so als ich habe die wahl
stehen mit zehn noch gar nicht gedacht
als ich hab' ich habe man so etwas ganz
gedacht hat sie ziemlich komplett wo
habt ihr ja aber ich habe noch überhaupt
möchte die sind ausgezählt
das schönste an also das ding früher wir
hatten keine iphones keine will los kein
garnichts 40 und joshua und aber bis der
frühere hat die früher hatten wir keine
handys wie gesagt das andere wort auch
noch keine playstation wir hatten den
besten sich nicht sie müssen sich
vorstellen dass wir für den marketplace
[Musik]
ich habe das ding jetzt müsst ihr und
heute hat heute hat einfach die ganze
welt ist denn da wird der arsch sind
weil ich sonst ist ja kein beibringen
was hat dich auch meine geile pilz lebt
ist hat und immer mit gummi denn
vergesst es darüber sprechen auch gleich
weitergehen
ja da sind wir beim thema samstag und
dann die ganze nacht über auf jeden fall
jetzt eigene zorc will ich habe doch
gesagt ich will überlassen und nicht auf
instagram rumsitzen die vision kurz
design bei analverkehr stehe ich gern
geblieben
auch david leute denken man braucht kein
kondom weil man ja durch den arzt nicht
schwanger werden kann vielen willst
keine frage also an sorry ich bin schon
zweimal gewonnen schon zweimal musste
aber schon viel wichtigere frage ist und
warum
jan muss wird man vom küssen schwanger
ja genau das fragen welche bei gute
frage ich habe auch schon gut bleibt
bekommen wir also von kräften wird man
nicht schwanger
ihr könnt euch knutschen alle machen ja
da waren wir jetzt hier
beim kunden auch in tome
also ich denke das ist sehr sehr wichtig
vor allem nein hab ich das mitbekommen
hier
ich glaube das war in ungarn da waren da
waren etwas auf klassenfahrt zu 13
diese 13 jährige dann kam die wiederum
vier waren einfach schwanger overkott
leute von anfang geplant
ich meine die waren echt die also
ungeplant angehörigen platte scheiße mit
so hätten die man das video gucken
berichtet das video verbreitet sind noch
da wird richtig die sonne hat sich
kondome kaffee vor allem die schlechte
krankheiten wie hiv tripper und wisst
ihr was ich immer machen müsst ihr müsst
einfach ein gummi drüberziehen oder
gummi für die frau und ist so eine
vagina muss die kondome oder so
das ging jetzt man die leute die älter
sind weil sex es auch erst erlaubt ab 14
jahre also bitte mach unis benutzen und
ja dass hier keine geschlecht und das
ist schon älter
nur wenn der junge halt nicht nur 17 ist
werden ihre 13 ihr geschwängert dann ist
das bisschen blöd entschuldigung ich
hab' ich habe mit 15 53 jährigen dem
bett also an sorry das ist echt so ein
song der war folge bringt wenn man
erster hersteller und ja
ich hörte noch doppelt wenn man kann ja
oft in japan kann auch dann noch wenn er
länger schon zusammen seid könnt ihr
natürlich auch wenn denn beide wissen
dass sie keine geschlechtskrankheiten
habt könnt ihr auch kondome weglassen
aber immer schön vorsichtig aber zu 99
die regeln aber ganz ehrlich wenn ihr
mal die pille vergisst dann kriegt der
baby ohne könnte das nicht versorgen was
hat sie nicht ausreicht oder echt so
leute da musst du echt aufpassen
deswegen immer mitkommen dachtest du
bist mein hintergrund geladen
man kann auch man kann auch nicht zwei
kogel also einkommen und dann noch einen
gegentreffer geht gar nicht weil das
fahrrad sicher und man darf ja auch
keine creme drauf bahn außer gleich viel
oder so und wird auch mal was dazu sagen
gehört doch gesagt das video besteht
sondern uns bitte ich würde darin du
kannst das einfach am besten
hier gibt es das video gehe ich und
locker zehn minuten das ganze mit eurer
eltern wissen was mir gesagt ich finde
wir sind besser als doktor sommer ja
auch machen lassen dort nach oben da und
checkt hier die die ganze kanäle aus in
der video beschreibung und zeigt auf
doktor sommer das ist alles nur klar
china hört auf mich ich weiß alles
besser
christian anderes video war wir hoffen
dass hat euch denn noch gefallen und
vergesst einen daumen nach oben zu geben
und war nahezu abonniert und wenig und
was ich noch sagen wollte vergesst das
gummi nabu die oder die pille oder die
martina hennies
[Gelächter]